firstly what is the rationale for
delaying the reopening of schools
by a week well what we're going to be
seeing is over 85 percent of
primary schools welcoming back children
on
monday of next week but we have had to
take
some additional action in certain areas
where uh
covert rates have been particularly high
and for public health advice is that
actually by
delaying the opening of some schools is
is being essential but in terms of a
secondary
year groups the reason that we have
moved that back is so that we give
all schools every single school every
single college
that teaches secondary age pupils the
opportunity to roll out a
mass testing regime making sure that we
root out this coronavirus
it's not just about making it safer for
pupils it's not just about making it
safer for those who work in schools
but actually it's about rooting out
coronavirus in our communities and we
did need to give schools a little bit
extra time
if we're moving from the position of
offering schools the opportunity to do
this
to uh telling them that we expected them
to do it
for all secondary school pupils so will
there be mass testing in schools and if
so
is a weak enough time to prepare to have
a functioning system
uh we're absolutely confident as it is
we'll be seeing
the um the all the testing equipment
that is needed for schools being
delivered on the 4th of january
schools have already had notice of
the guidance of what they need to do
they've also had notification of the
extra 78 million pounds worth of money
that we're offering up
helping them support it get the right
staff in there and if i can also
take the opportunity to thank our
brilliant armed forces
1500 of who will be there to support
schools that are having some real
problems and real challenges in getting
this set
up so in those exceptional cases where
schools are having problems
uh the armed forces are there to help
and support them
to get these testing centers set up so
they're going to see the mass testing
of secondary school pupils this is
really important for
you know you know we're taking the fight
uh to coronavirus we're
rooting it out of communities because
all at every stage
we're making sure that children are able
to benefit from getting a brilliant
education that we want all our children
to get
teachers and unions seem to disagree
with the notion of having a functioning
system i'm just looking at this joint
statement from the teaching unions
including
naht and the nas uwt
they've said it's an inoperable plan for
most schools in colleges
they they don't seem to to agree with
what you're saying
well i very much respect the fact that
they maybe take a different view but
we have every confidence that this is a
mass testing regime
we're giving schools enough time in
order to be able to implement it
this is why moving from an optionality
of being able to implement it and saying
that we want every school to implement
it
we've given them that extra week in
order to make sure it is properly bedded
in is properly ready uh to be delivered
it's really important that we get as
much testing out there into the
community
because obviously for every case that we
identify among our people
you're also very it's very likely that
you're
identifying a household there's also uh
you know maybe other cases of
coronavirus in it
uh but what is so essential is that that
household is
isolating uh in order to protect the
whole community
so this isn't something that's just
about benefiting schools
it's about benefiting all communities is
about
beating back coronavirus you know there
is a new strain out there
we're having to take extraordinary
actions and you know
it's really important to thank all those
head teachers and teachers
who've done so much all through this you
know incredibly difficult year and
i know we're asking them to do even more
but it's so important that we do this
in order to beat this virus and on that
point of thanking um head teachers and
teachers and many people asking why
teachers aren't being prioritized for
the vaccine given that
many experts urine scientists including
are urging you to
close schools you're going against that
um
why aren't teachers being prioritized
for the vaccine well
as you're well aware that we've
prioritized in that sort of first wave
of vaccines
those people who are most vulnerable who
are most likely
uh to be in a position of uh being
hospitalized as a result of catching
uh covid i i think everyone's
recognizing the epicenter for the
increase in infections and transmissions
are they not i think we all recognize
where the first vaccines need to go to
those people who are most likely to lose
their lives as a result of catching
covid
and of course there are teachers who are
those who are critically extremely
vulnerable there are those teachers who
will be
uh caught in that first wave of
roll out of that of this amazing vaccine
but then when we look at future waves of
the roll out of a vaccine it's
really important that uh you know as you
can imagine as education secretary alby
uh wanting to see uh teachers and all
those support staff
uh being up there on that list uh
getting that vaccine on a personal level
secretary of state i mean do you think
teachers should be prioritized when it
comes to receiving the vaccine
like healthcare workers uh well what
we've seen in terms of this first
roll out is that actually those who are
most likely
to be in harm's way as a result of
actually getting coronavirus those who
are going to be
affected by getting coronavirus and
hospitalized
are going to be guessing that in future
waves obviously this is a decision that
will be made across government
uh it'd be great to see more teachers uh
right up there
getting the vaccine but it's got to be
made on
a clinical judgment as to how best we
deal
and beat this virus when will primary
schools
return to to school you've given a date
for secondary schools but not primary
schools
uh well uh we we did actually uh that's
the fourth of january so
uh primary schools are going to be
returning on fourth of january
not all of them though there are there
are a number that will remain closed
yeah so over 85 percent of primary
schools will be opening as
uh absolutely as expected on the 4th of
january
for those schools within the contingency
framework
where as a result of uh public health
advice
we've delayed their opening that's for a
two-week period and there'll be a review
of that status
as you reported just earlier um you know
for the week before so obviously we want
to give schools for notice
and parents importantly the notice and
children
that hopefully their schools will be
reopening but what we want to see is uh
we'll be seeing uh over 85 percent of
primary schools
opening on the fourth of january uh we
want to see
those schools that uh are sadly not able
to open on before for january
to be opening up the earliest secretary
i'm sorry to interrupt him times against
us i mean there are 50 areas that don't
have a return date um as of yet that is
a significant numbers and there are
anomalies that do exist when it comes to
closures if you look at kensington um
it's closed but greenwich bridge isn't
um in greenwich
they've had 756 cases per 100 000 people
in the latest week
the 20th of december to the 26th
kensington in chelsea has 492 cases per
100 000 people
in the latest week the 20th december to
the 26th of december the average area in
england
um is 275. you can understand how many
people will be
confused at the end of the decision that
you've made um well
it's sorry to correct you but red bridge
is actually included in those areas that
are actually
uh having the sort of schools close but
uh the
work that was done with the department
for health who identified areas where
it was either a very high rate or there
was
using their latest data we're seeing
very sharp
increases in the number of cases
or equally the pressures on hospitals
in that area and the clinical needs
these were all the considerations that
were taken into account
but what i want to say and this will
come as no surprise to you whatsoever
i want to see schools you know any
school that's
uh closed for those first two weeks
opening
at the earliest possible opportunity i i
don't want to see any schools closed as
you can imagine as education secretary
but we only do this in the most extreme
situations where the public health
advice the scientific advice is that we
need to do it
because i want to see every child in
school
getting that great education that's why
we're rolling out this mass testing
regime in secondary schools
reducing the amount of time that
children will have to spend outside of
school
making sure that they're having the
opportunity to be in school at their
desk studying
learning and being prepared for the
future but for many people these
positions
seem to have come very late in the day
warnings were
were given weeks if not months ago but
if we can move on to the the tier
system um secretary of state i mean
we've got huge waves of the country
um now in tier four is tier four
still the right approach many of your
own scientists are urging
you to introduce a full national
lockdown
uh the tiering system is absolutely the
right approach what we need to be doing
is creating a thing
and there won't be a national lockdown
in weeks to come
we're absolutely uh we're taking the
absolute
right approach to a pursuit of a tiering
system
it's really important those areas have
the opportunity to
move down the tearing system as well as
having to sometimes move areas up the
tearing system
this is a robust approach and you know
as so many of us are in the situation of
having to live in tier four areas
we recognize that there are impositions
uh that this provide
you know has on everyone's lives but it
is the right approach it's the proper
approach
um you know and this is a robust
approach so i'm confident that we won't
be moving into a national lockdown
situation
uh because the tearing structure is the
right
the right place to be but i don't think
people want to be in a situation is you
know if you don't have to impose those
restrictions on people
you don't want to impose those
restrictions on people that for me is
always got to be the right approach
as i said um this announcement has come
pretty late in the day i mean do you
apologize to parents teachers and
and children for this announcement um
coming so late so what would your
message to them be
i think we all recognize that if we go
back a few weeks where there was
no new variant of kovid none of us would
have been
expecting us to be having to take the
actions even
whether it's in regards to schools
whether it's in regards to the
tier four moves that the government has
had to make
but is the government that's having to
respond this incredible pace
to a global pandemic and then a new
variant of that
virus it's not what any of us would want
to do
it's not a decision of us that any of us
would
be wanting to having to implement but
we've had to do that
because you know circumstances have
dictated it
and i think the british public expect
the government to do
what is right and even though that is
sometimes uncomfortable
it is taking the right actions dealing
with these extraordinary times